the nfl desperately wants college
football season to proceed even though
the nfl would backfill saturdays if it
can pull that off if the college
football season doesn't go forward the
nfl wants it to go forward for many
reasons including you know it's kind of
hard to have a draft in 2021 if there's
no scouting to be done of games played
by college football teams in 2020
and guys
uh
look
the articles are out there the comments
are out there from the commissioners of
the various conferences
i think the end result for college
football in 2020 is going to be each
school
will decide whether or not it can pull
it off
and we're talking about the nfl's
scheduling issues today
and the schedule comes out tomorrow
night i think at some point these
college programs are gonna have a
nightmare where you look at your
schedule three or four of the teams that
you're due to play aren't playing this
year what are you gonna do for those
three or four weeks can you find
somebody else who is playing but i
really do feel like it's going to be a
piecemeal patchwork one school at a time
maybe one conference at a time maybe
most teams from one conference but not
all of them but college football season
if it happens in 2020 peter it's going
to be far crazier than whatever the nfl
is able to pull off
yeah i've been thinking about this i
read a really good story about this by
pete thamel at yahoo
and it was it sounds like what you're
saying mike not really an every man for
himself kind of deal
but it's going to be a situation where
when i first heard about this i started
saying hey look
if if i were one of these commissioners
of the sec the acc
you know the big 12
wherever
i would i'd basically say hey look
let's have a
a meeting on like july 15th let's see
where we are
and let's make a schedule
so that all the dates that everyone has
lost because of the schools that might
not be playing this year
let's fill them so that there would be
some real competition and some good
games
uh so that you don't have to play let's
say
presbyterian one week and then wofford
the next week to fill holes in your
schedule and i'm not criticizing them
because sometimes they do play those
teams but i'm saying that i think that
might allow teams
to be able to fill their schedules and
do it logically with some
good opponents but again i think it's
one of those things that we just don't
know yet
but i i agree and my antennae is raised
to see if college football is going to
be able to have any sort of normal
season
i i mean man do they have a tough road
in front of them it's just there's so
many more moving parts in college
football as compared to the nfl first
off you know
all the kids on the college football
team i mean most of these major programs
got 100 120 guys on their team all year
long you know once kids get back into
school into college and now what are you
going to do with the football team are
you going to integrate them with the
rest of the student body or are we just
going to like just go up i hope no one
gets sick are we not even going to test
them are we going to test the school the
students every day and the players can
you actually like kind of quarantine the
college football players arrest away
from the rest of you know the student
body i just don't know let alone like
you know certain parts of our country
have certain you know beliefs or ideas
about this covet 19. you know as we're
seeing some of the southern states are a
little more lacks with their rules and
we we're hearing and seeing a little
science that the warm weather is better
so what if we start the college football
season and then all of a sudden it gets
to late fall and a school like michigan
is in the north and everybody's kind of
telling us right now when the weather
turns again that this thing could
research you know could have a
resurgence
you know what what was what are we
supposed to do what's what's michigan
supposed to do if all of a sudden
there's another outbreak at their school
and there's you know a bunch of guys in
the team that have covered 19. you know
to me that's where it's just there's so
many questions and things to deal with
in a con at college football
man is it going to be hard to
orchestrate to have a real football
season for them
and i think it's a given at this point
you can't have college football without
college you can't bring just the
football team back and keep the rest of
the campus shut down that's the point
where they admit that the college
football players are only there to make
money they're not there to play football
as some sort of an extension to the
college experience like maybe it once
was decades ago now these guys are
unpaid workers who are there to generate
billions of dollars collectively for the
college football machinery so if you
can't put classes back in session and
have people on campus you can't get away
with that that mental gymnastics of
justifying bringing those kids back but
chris to one of the points you made you
know the the college football players
will be likely to self quarantine
because of what we discussed yesterday
with this concept of testing if you're
going to get tested before you go into
the practice facility every time you
show up you don't want to be positive
you want to be able to practice you want
to be able to play you don't want to let
your team down you don't want to miss
out on the thing that you love doing
which is playing football that is going
to cause these guys to be even more
careful about not testing positive not
because they're afraid of the virus or
they think they're going to get sick or
they think they're going to die no they
just don't want the result of that test
that they have to do before they show up
for every practice and every game to
come back positive and they get shut
down for two or three weeks so i i think
that that will kind of take care of
itself that the players will voluntarily
stay within a bubble they'll keep
everyone away because they don't want to
come back positive so if we get to the
point where everyone is on campus
together i think the college football
players will
enforce it among themselves and they'll
want to do it you'll you'll want to stay
away from everyone else so you might
show up positive
i'll just throw this out there but what
do you do like a lot of these these
college football teams are in a
dormitory
with the normal student body that's to
me where it'll get confusing like i can
just speak to my personal experience at
texas i was in the biggest dorm along
with the rest of the football team
on campus and i believe it was over like
10 000 kids just in this dorm it was
that big it was like a 20-something
story building so there's another issue
too like yeah the player might want to
sell quarantine but damn he's gonna have
to go up the elevator in that dorm and
then he's gonna have to go up the
stairwell and probably have to get some
food in the cafeteria and things like
that that's to me where it just becomes
really challenging for a college player
as compared to an nfl player who has
money has means can go to the office
every day get in his car go back to his
apartment or house or whatever it may be
in quarantine that way i just think it's
a little bit more of a struggle for the
college student
peter i think one of the things that
colleges are going to have to do my mike
and chris is i i heard a really
interesting interview the other day with
the brown university president now
obviously this is a totally different
situation it's not a gigantic campus in
the ivy league it's different
but the brown university president
basically made this point
that there's already 320 students living
on campus through this pandemic because
of all the people who couldn't go home
because maybe they live overseas they
were banned from traveling back home or
whatever they couldn't go home and so
they've kind of gotten a head start on
figuring out how to live with this and i
think like you saw the houston texans
the other day they hired basically
uh a cleaning specialist you know who's
going to tell them how to do proper
hygiene how to do proper cleaning in
this era of covid19 so just like the
people at brown university are getting a
head start look at the university of
texas i would bet you a lot of money
that if the football team is going to go
back and is going to start playing games
that they will do a lot and a lot
different than the old days where
everybody all merged in the same dorm
and i don't even know what they would do
but there's going to be a different way
of living on college campuses not only
for the general population but certainly
for the athletic population
yeah and you know
as chris was explaining it as peter as
you were talking about it there's just
this nagging sense that whether it's at
the nfl level or the college level and
it's more prevalent the college level
every question you raise
that you answer it spawns more questions
and then
those answers create more questions and
then more questions and i don't know how
you get it to a point where anyone is
sufficiently confident and comfortable
that this is all going to work and even
with an explosion in testing whether
diagnostic testing or antibody testing
the virus is still going to be there
it's still going to migrate it's still
going to get to people what do you do
about the professors in these classes if
you're going to have college and college
football how do you protect them if
they're older or if they're in risk
groups i worry about the people who
don't realize they have health
conditions that put them in risk groups
and they're going to find out the hard
way that they had diabetes plenty of
people don't find out they have diabetes
for a long time until they crash and get
really sick from it you you may have
type 1 or type 2 and not even realize it
yet and then you get covert 19 and
that's it so there's just a lot a lot of
of issues and concerns here and i think
it does make it much more difficult to
have a college football season i know
there's been talk about playing it from
february to may which would even more
complicate the nfl draft and how do you
justify taking guys who played football
until may and have them play in the
following september from the standpoint
of overall health and safety so the nfl
wants to get this done wants college
football to happen
and even if it is some teams even if
it's just the big schools the alabamas
the clemsons etc
it it's
man this last 10 minutes has made me
think it it is a herculean task chris to
pull this off
yeah it really is it is it's way tougher
than what the nfl has to deal with and
you know we've made a lot of the great
points i mean you're right i mean how do
you do this if students aren't there can
you really trust kids that are 18 19
years old i certainly know on my texas
team you know if something like this was
going on
would i sit here and go oh i trust all
120 guys are going home after practice
are gonna quarantine themselves no i
would have some guys going man i know
he's gonna go chase girls here and this
guy's gonna go play an xbox fortnight
tournament or whatever with a bunch of
guys and who knows what the hell happens
tomorrow what virus is in our locker
room so it's still really early to tell
at this point um but you know the sec
seems steadfast right now and they're
going to have a college football season
and i think where a lot of these schools
are really panicking is
as you guys know
college football supports so many other
programs within the universities it's
such a huge money maker it's not just
about the sports they pay for all
different programs throughout the school
the college football programs really
keep these schools running and afloat
and in the you know positive margin as
far as money's concerned and i think
they're they're surely panicking about
that right now as well
yeah and you know the one thing that
college football is going to have a very
difficult time doing that we assume the
nfl will just do without flinching if
they have to is play games without fans
how do you justify a college football
game without that pageantry that goes
along right without the fans in the
stands without the kids there again it
comes closer and closer to acknowledging
that college football really isn't about
college it's about making as much money
as you can
televising these games and and the the
financial ramifications are different as
well it's not like a given college
football game generates as much money as
a given nfl game does but you know if if
you are in states where they say sorry
we're not going to let people gather in
hundreds or thousands
um it's just not going to happen the
decision is going to be made california
if california's not willing to open up
stadiums for the nfl they're not going
to open up stadiums for the colleges
there so no usc no ucla no stanford no
cal
um you know a lot of it's going to be
taken care of that way because i just
can't imagine any of these you know you
could have you could have this almost
like a a you know a harlem globetrotters
which never has a home game they're
always playing on the road you could
could you have a college team that just
doesn't play at home peter and plays all
its games on the road in a given year
i mean i think a school like stanford
would say there's there's this too much
this is too much stanford i'm sure in
look i'm not i don't have any idea about
the the effect on the endowment or
anything like that but
you know stanford is not going to have
the same decision-making process as
alabama is they're just not
and and and i think the one thing i
would say and i think chris is
absolutely right the one reason why i
think you should really look at college
football
in the real hotbed areas as being a
little bit different
is because
it isn't only the fact hey we want to we
want to have a sense of normalcy here
you know we want to we want to get on
with our lives it isn't only that
it is the fact that
interstate commerce and television
contracts and advertising and basically
the flow of regular america you don't
think donald trump is going to be out on
september 20th
calling for the resumption of college
football i mean you know he's doing it
now for all sports so there's going to
be an awful lot of and i don't even want
to say the word pressure but there's
going to be a lot of the workings of
society basically we are three months
away
from really having to make
a hard decision about whether college
football games are going to be played
and you know a lot can happen in three
months
but i i and and i don't think that all
schools will end up playing but i do
think enough will end up playing so that
you know the machinery known as college
football will grind on in some form or
fashion this season
kevin warren the big ten
commissioner recently said that they are
at least six weeks away from having to
make key decisions so it's coming it's
coming and a lot can change in six weeks
look at what's happened over the course
of the last six
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports